[موسيقى]
نحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش الملف الثاني اي
من قليله تفصل عن انطلاق جوله الاعاده
الحاسمه للانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه بين
رئيس التحالف الحاكم اردوغان ورئيس تحالف
المعارضه
يصدم فيها اردوغان بانقسام حزبه حول الخطه
الاقتصاديه بين تمسك مسؤولين في الحزب رفع
الفائده وتشبث في مسؤولين اخرين حكوميين
بخفضها في اردوغان المتقدم بنتائج الجوله
الاولى من الانتخابات كان اعزز من فرص
فوزه اختيار السياسي سنان دعمه باصوات
ناخذه في جوله الاعاده ولكن في لعبه
الانتخابات تبقى المفاجات حاضره اميت
ازداج الذي خاض الجوله الاولى من
الانتخابات العامه متحالفا مع اوغانبي
تحالف الاجداد قرار وبدون مقدمات الوقوف
الى جانب كمال كلش دار اوغلو داعيا الى
التصويت لصالح مرشح المعارضه كليتشار
اوغلو في الجوله الثانيه في المقابل تخوف
تقارير اعلاميه بشان الدعم الذي حصل عليك
من الاصوات الكرديه لتشتد المنافسه
الحاسمه على كرسي الرئيس الثالث عشر في ظل
مفاجات تخالف الكثير من التوقعات وحتى من
الاستطلاعات
انقسام بحزب اردوغان حول الخطه الاقتصاديه
اجتماعات بحزب العداله والتنميه لتبني
سياسه جديده للرفع التدريجي لاسعار
الفائده واعتماد برنامج محدد الهدف
للاقراض العاملون على الخطه الجديده لا
يفكرون في تشديد السياسه النقديه بتدابير
اكثر حده لكنهم يفكرون في مسار اكثر تدرجا
يؤكد من جديد على سعر الفائده الرئيسي
للبنك المركزي التركي في اسواق الاقراض
احدى الخيارات الاخرى هي الاستعانه باحدى
المؤسسات العامه قسم اخر يرغب بالتمسك
بالبرنامج الحالي لتعزيز الصادرات وتحفيز
النمو الاقتصادي من خلال خفض اسعار
الفائده ومن خلال اسواق الصرف الاجنبي
والائتمان والديون الخاضعه لرقابه شديده
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من اسطنبول
جواد جاك المحلله السياسي ومن اسطنبول
كذلك تقع دوجلو الكاتب المحلل السياسي
اهلا بكم ضيوف في الكرام استاذ جواد قبل
ثلاثه ايام يوم 28 بالتحديد ستكون تركيا
على موعد مع الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه قبل ايام قليله لمن
الكفه ترجح في هذه الاثناء بحسب قراءتك
تحيه لك ورضاك مدى مشاهدينا الكرام طبعا
المعادله لصالح الرئيس اردوغان شيئا كما
يبدو المعارضه تحافظ ان تجلب اصواتها
الناخبين من كل الاطراف اليوم
اعلن حزب
يساري الاخضر حزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه
السابقه
اتبعهم الاكراد خاصه
للتصويت لصالح
كمالكوليسترولو كما كان في الجوله الاولى
وايضا
المعارضه تحاول ان
تجلب الرئيس اردوغان الى الشاشات بمعنى
انك ملك
الرئيس اردوغان للنقاش
في الشاشات امام شعب التركي مرات عديده
يعني من البدايه كان يدعوه لكن الرئيس
اردوغان كان يرفضه واليوم قال اجابه انه
هو كما الكوليسترول يريد النقاش معي ما هو
اثركم
وما هي خدمات المعارضه للشعب التركي حتى
اناقش معكم طيب هل المعارضه تقدر ان تبني
جسور مطارات طرق هذه وظيفه الحكومه طبعا
هؤلاء في المعارضه لا توجد بيدهم اشياء
وميزانيه وغير ذلك ولهذا سبب الدعوه
مستمره لكن الرئيس اردوغان يرفضه جمله
تفصيلا لكن بشكل عام يعني جلب القوميين
وحزب الناصر الى
التصفيط لصالح كمال الكوليستر اوغلو ممكن
ان ياتي حماس في صفوف
القوميين وفي صفوف المحايدين بالنتيجه كما
الكوليسترول في قمه القضيه لجلب الاصوات
يعني لا يوجد طريق غير هذا وهو قد قام به
لكن
القرار قرار الشعبي ولكن حضرتك لما تتكلم
عن حضرتك لما تتكلم عن القوميدوس داك
البعض يقول بانه هذا الدعم قد يكلف كلتش
دار اوغلو وخاصه سوره المصافحه بينه وما
اشيع فيما بعد عن انه
ربما يكون قد وعد اوميدوزاك بامكانيه ان
يتسلم وزاره الداخليه فيما بعد مؤيد
كالجدار اوغلو نفو الموضوع ولكن راجع
الاشاعه وانتشرت قبل ايام قليله وبالتالي
سيد طه عوده اوغل من جهه هناك دعم
للقوميين او على الاقل خلينا نقتصر على
هذه الشخصيه لكي الجدار اوغلو ولكن جدار
اوغلو كذلك مدعوم من الاكراد تحدث ضيفي عن
اليسار الاخضر ولكن هناك كذلك مجموعه
كبيره من الاحزاب التي تدعم الاكراد
هي متوجهه لدعمها وهذا التنوع الشديد قد
يفقد
الشخصيه او المرشح بوصلته هل هذا يمكن ان
يفيد او ان يضر به
الجميع يعني في هذه النقطه الجزئيه
السذريهم يعني يجب ان نتوقف عن هناك تطور
جديد حصل في الجوله الثانيه على عكس
الجوله الاولى الجوله الاولى كنت نتحدث عن
طالب السداسيه الان نتحدث عن شخصين
خلال اليومين الماضيين انا تصوري كما اشرت
المصافحه هي كلفت السيد كمال الكثير كما
انه اطلق النار على قدميه لماذا اليوم
تصريح او البيان الصدر من الحزب شعوب
الديمقراطيه او التيار الاخضر الكردي هو
حقيقه هو اعلن دعمه لكريستار اوروبا ولكن
انا توقعاتي سوف يكون هناك عزوف من بعض
الشخصيات او بعض الناخبين الاكراد للتصويت
حتى اذا تحدثنا عن اوميتو هو نسبته واحد
ونصف في المئه
يعني اذا حصل 44 في الجوله الماضيه نفترض
نحو حسابيه سته واربعين ولكن على كل
الاحوال يعني حاليا هناك يعني اخطاء
ارتكبت او ارتكبها السيد كم هو خاصه فيما
يتعلق بلغه الخطاب التي يعني هو نتحدث عنه
يساري علماني الليبرالي يتحول في لحظه ما
الى قوم متشدد يعني حتى سنانو كان المتطرف
والقوم المتطرف جدا يعني تحدث وقال بان
حديث السيد كمالك لم يقنعني وخاصه فيتعلق
بموضوع معايدات اللاجئين لذا هو توجه الى
السيد اردوغان وقال بانه هناك قاسم مشترك
بيننا وبين قوسين وهم مكافحه الارهاب
وايضا فيما يتعلق بموضوع معالجه ملف
اللاجئين يعني اردوغان لم يقل سوف نبقى
اللاجئين هنا في تركيا سوف نقوم باعادتهم
خلال فتره ولكن وفق هناك في اتفاقيات
دوليه ووفق هناك فيما يتعلق بالبنيه
التحتيه لدى الخطاب الحكومه كان هو مطمئن
يعني ان كان للناخب بشكل عام او حتى للسيد
سنان
لذا انا التصور اعتقد هناك يعني فجوه
واسعه خلال يعني تبع ناها خلال الايام
الاخيره الماضيه اما بين الطرفين ولهذا
السبب تحدثنا سيد جواد عن خلطه او عن وصفه
متنوعه جدا متناقضه يسار قومه دعمنا
الاكراد هذه الخلطه هل يمكن ان تضر بكليتش
دار اوغلو بحسب رايك بحسب متابعتك طبعا
الاوساط في داخل تركيا
[موسيقى]
صحيح انه طبعا خرجوا عن المتعود يعني انه
مثلا نفس هو شخص يساري علماني لكن ترى انه
من البدايه كان قد اجتمع حزب السعاده
اليمني والاسلامي شيئا ما من المتشددين
نعم هذه الامور عاديه من البدايه في
التحالفات يعني على الجميع ان يتعود على
التحالفات انه مشكل من انواع مختلفه طبعا
الامر صعب جدا انتقادات سوف تتوجه اليهما
حتى هذا الحزب حزب النصر انظروا مثلا
كسبوا اثنين فاصل اثنين بالمئه من الاصوات
لكن يجبرون كمال على شروط غريبه جدا رغم
ارادته لكن لجلب الاصوات هو قد خضع وهناك
انتقادات موجه اليه لكن نفس القضيه
بالنسبه الى تحالف الجمهور ايضا موجود
يعني
هناك من الاسلاميين المتشددين مثل هدى
يقف مع القوميين ايضا وحتى العلمانيين
والوطنين والاسلاميين المعتدلين في نفس
التحالف هذه الامور موجوده بالنتيجه كل
يلعب باوراقه
القويه حتى هذه الايام
التركيز على اللاجئين بشكل غريب جدا من
قبل
حزب الشعب الجمهوري لكم الكوليستر اوغلو
مطابقا مع حزبه القومي المتطرف نستغرب لكن
في نفس الوقت نعرف انه هذه الافكار
المتطرفه القوميه لا تناسب مع الشخصيه كما
الكوليستر ولا مع حزبه لكن لجلب الاصوات
للاطاحه على الرئيس
قال بانه ليس في ان يكون على مبدا وخاصه
فيما يهم موضوع اللاجئين ملف اللاجئين ملف
كبير جدا في داخل التركي ومن ثم يعود
يدعم او ليطرح افكار مقابله مهما تكون
التفاصيل استاذ طه عوده اوغلو لما نعود
للجوله الاولى نلاحظ تقارب كبير بين النسب
تقريبا 49 مقابل 45
لكلتشدار اوغلو والبعض يشير الى انقسام
شديد داخل اوساط الناخبين الاتراك نعلم
بان الجوله الثانيه لن تبنى على انقاذ
الجوله الاولى سنعيد الحساب من الصفر ولكن
هل هناك مؤشرات يمكن ان نستخلصها من هذه
النسب
يعني انا التصور اعتقد من خلال الجوله
الاولى يمكن قراءه النتائج الجوله الثانيه
نتحدث عن نسبه 2 مليون ونصف شخص او خمسه
في المئه ليست بالنسبه البسيطه
واليوم او بالامس انتهت التصويت بالخارج
تتذكرين في الجوله الماضيه كانت الاصوات
هناك اقبال كبير والاصوات توجهت للرئيس
اردوغان هذه المره على الرغم من التوقعات
ان يكون عدد الاقبال قليل لكن لاحظنا يعني
تقريبا ما يقارب اثنين مليون شخص صوتوا
بالخارج واصوات الخارج عاده تعود للحزب
الحاكم هذه النقطه نقطه اخرى النسبه التي
حصل عليها الرئيس اردوغان لا اتحدث من
ناحيه حسابيه والناحيه السياسيه تحدث 49
بالمئه ولكن الاصوات او الناخبين الذين
صوتوا لاردوغان انا تصوري سوف يقومون
بالتصويت له مره اخرى المشكله تكمن في
المعارضه وخاصه لاحظنا ان هناك خيبه امل
وصدمه كبيره يعني السيد كمال اوغلو عندما
هو يعرف بان هناك لا يوجد امل ولكن هو
يحاول قدر الامكان ان يدفع الناخبين
للتصويت في الجوله الثانيه ايضا
لماذا حضرتك وكانك تحجم من النسبه التي
تحصل عليها سيد كلتش دار اوغلو هو تحصل
على 45% ويمكن ان تشاركنا هذه النقطه سيد
جواد تحصل على 45% فالانتخابات السابقه
مثلا في تركيا لم يتحصل محرم ان جاء على
ما يفوق الاربعين حسب المائه حصل اعتقد
على 36% حتى في انتخابات 2014 لتحصل على
30 او 30 وقليل
30 قليل صحيح طيب ليس هناك لم يكن هناك
طيله سنوات عديده احد في المرتبه الثانيه
وتحصل على هذه النسبه المهمه كيف يعني
لماذا حضرتك تتحدث عن انه حتى وانت حصل
على هذه النسبه غير قادر ان يواجه اردوغان
سيد جواد قادر ان تفيدنا في هذه النقطه
حضرتك
طبعا يعني هو قادر ان يواجهه كيف بالنتيجه
الرئيس اردوغان عندما وصل الى
49.5
معناه انه اغلب الشعب التركي لا يؤيدونه
هنا النقطه المهمه هل كمالك قادر ان يجلب
باقي باقي الاصوات لصالحه هنا يجهدون يعني
هنا يشتغل بالنتيجه هناك من المحايدين
الذين لم ياتوا لصناديق الاقتراع في المره
السابقه وايضا الرئيس اردوغان حذر
حذر اتباعه من الحزب انه لا تكون
السكرانين عن الانتصار السابق في الجوله
الاولى عليكم بحذر ان تستعد تستعدون
للجوله الثانيه وغير ذلك كما الكوليسترول
لانتصار كبير حققه عندما وصل الى 45% لم
يكن اي معارضه فيه
هذين العقدين وصل الى هذه النسبه لكن هناك
كانت توقعات انه بعد هذه الاحداث الكبيره
التي جرت في تركيا من ازمات الاقتصاديه
قضيه الزلزال وغير ذلك يعني كان قادرا ان
يجلب اكثر من هذا وان يصل الى اكثر من
خمسين بالمئه لانه
الانتقادات موجهه اليها هكذا المعارضه لم
تقدم شخصيه جديده وجه جديد في السياسه
التركيه ليقابل رئيس اردو يفوز
حضرتك سيده جواد استشعرت مثلا حضرتك وكانك
تريد ان تقول بانه في مراحل فقد فيها
اردوغان اشعاعه في المقابل اخفقت المعارضه
في ايجاد شخص قادر على مواجهته هل هذا
التعبير صحيح
يعني نعم بالنتيجه الشعب التركي كانوا
يريدون نعم هناك تراجع لشعبيه حزب الحاكم
الرئيس اردوغان لكن الشعب يريدون ان
يواجهه الشخصيه اقوى من كمال هنا تعليقات
اكثر في دقيقه لو سمحت
صحيح يعني انا اتفق معك في هذه الجمله
ولكن بس ارد على السيد جواد يعني عندما
تحدث ان اردوغان خمسين بالمئه ترفضه هناك
55% ترفض ولكن اتصور المعرض كانت لها فرصه
كبيره يعني لو انتخبت او جاءت بامام اوغلو
ممكن ان تحسم الجوله من الجوله الاولى نعم
انا اتفقا هناك بعض الاخطاء ارتكبت خاصه
حزب العداله والتنميه وحتى تراجع شعبيه
الرئيس رجب اردوغان لكن المعارضه هي اخفقت
هذه المره في اختيار الشخص الذي يقف وجه
الرئيس سننتظر ربما تحمل هذه الجوله
الثانيه مفاجات لا نعلم في كل الحالات
العربيه
ستغطي هذه الجوله الثانيه كذلك سنكون
حاضرين معكم في داخل التركي ومن خلال
التقارير من اسطنبول جوالاك المحلله
السياسي ومن اسطنبول الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي شكرا جزيلا لكم السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات